I've been sent in this question by a
viewer has to do with year 12
probability it goes like this Alan buys
four tickets in a raffle in which 100
tickets are sold together there are two
prizes in the raffle find the
probability that now
this muscle is interested in Part C find
the probability that Alan will win one
prize and I assume that means one prize
only because Part II says at least one
prize so this would be one prize or two
prizes so I guess that means one prize
and one prize alone I need help with
toss say I don't know how else to do the
question without the use of binomial
probability thank you okay now now
interests me because and this is a case
this kind of question is an example
where binomial probability is actually a
great way to solve this question it's a
I think it's a little more succinct and
elegant as a solution but as you may be
you know this appears in a two unit exam
or something like that this question can
be done without binomial probability so
I'm going to show you two ways to solve
it I'll solve it without binomial
probability and then I'll solve it with
binomial probability okay so let's get
this out of the way get some working
paper okay
so let's think about this what do we
know we've got Alan who's bought four
tickets right so that's kind of where
he's going to get his possibility for
winning a prize altogether there's a
hundred tickets and I've got two prizes
okay so let's think about this option
how would he get one prize how many ways
would be possible for him to get one
prize well since he's got four tickets
right I can think about each individual
ticket and their probabilities for
getting a prize or not getting a prize
okay so for instance let's think about
that first ticket what's the probability
that that gets a prize well since there
are hundred tickets in total and there
are two prizes okay that means that the
probability of getting the first ticket
getting a prize out of the four is two
out of 100
okay right now
if the first ticket has gotten a prize
then if he only has one prize that means
there's other three tickets don't get
prizes okay
well let's consider what's the
probability of those and because these
events are about to describe they happen
simultaneously with the first ticket
because he's got all four tickets I'm
gonna multiply these together right okay
now what happened he's he's going to get
no prize for this next ticket okay well
how many tickets are left which have no
prizes well he hasn't taken any of them
out and if there are two prizes that
means there are 98 which have no prize
right so that means the probability of
picking up a ticket with no prize after
he's gotten a ticket with a prize is 98
out of now it's not gonna be 98 out of
100 because there aren't a hundred
tickets anymore he's already drawn one
so it's gonna be ninety eight out of
nine you know okay all right
that's the first two tickets the third
ticket is also I'm not going to get a
prize now because he's taken out one if
they're non prize tickets
there'll be 97 left and the total number
of tickets because he's pulled out two
will be 98 and you can see the patterns
going to continue on for his fourth and
final ticket there will be ninety six
nine price tickets left and he's pulling
him out of a pool of 97 okay so what
have we got here this is a prize not a
prize not a prize I'm not for us so
here's one possible way of getting one
prize and one prize only but it's not
the only way right his first ticket
might not get the prize it might be the
second ticket baguette surprise right so
instead of this kind of arrangement I
might have the first ticket getting no
prize the second one give me the prize
and then the other two being the same
now let's just consider this option and
compare it to this one okay
what's the probability of the first
ticket not having a prize okay
well it's kind of like this one but
flipped around right in fact it's the
compliment
this event is a complement of this event
because to not get a prize well there's
98 different ways to do that 98
different no prize tickets and there's a
hundred left at the beginning before any
tickets have been chosen right all right
now that we get to the next one there's
a prize to go well there's two but again
one pricketts been taken out so there
are only no nine left
and then the rest of it proceeds as
usual because how many know price
tickets are left after one's been taken
out there'll be 97 and how many tickets
are there in total 98 and then off in
the end you've got 96 and then 97 total
right
okay now compare these two right the
first thing you'll notice is that the
denominators are the same 100 99 98 97
okay and that's because in each case as
you consider first second third and
fourth ticket you're picking from the
same size pool right
there's always 100 tickets to begin with
and then there's always 99 98 and the
last ticket there will always be 97 to
choose from now let's have a look at the
numerators the numerators are also the
same but they're in different order and
the different order reflects where the
prize comes in okay but it's always
going to be the same set of what's the
word favorable outcomes right there's
always a two that corresponds to one of
the prizes right there's always the 98
to 97 and then 96 okay it's just that
the order has switched around because
there's a no prize first around the
second okay so you can see this is my my
first way of winning what just one prize
here's my second way well there's two
more right there's this one having the
prize not in the second slot but in the
third one so there'd be n no prize no
prize prize no prize okay then there's a
fourth one having the prize right at the
very end no no no and then a prize now
you can see that the probabilities for
all of these are going to be the same
right
so you can work out what one of these is
and then you can multiply it by four
right so just before I move on from that
these four possibilities we just sort of
thought that out logically to work out
that there's going to be these four
options but you can draw if you like a
probability tree to arrive at the same
kind of conclusion and for a question
like this where it's got multiple parts
you know looking at this you're gonna
have to answer the same kinds of
questions for the same scenario but it's
just slightly different different
adjustments right so you can draw a
probability tree it looks something like
this okay and you can see the options
that we're after
there is the first prize okay I'm sorry
the prize on the first ticket there's
the one on the second ticket third the
fourth okay and if you worked out what
the probability on each of these
branches of the tree is they're going to
correspond to these fractions okay all
right so what's the actual answer then
I've got these four different ways and
these are independent of each other so
I'm going to add them up I'm gonna have
whatever this isn't multiply it by four
okay because all four of these ought to
be the same so I'm gonna get four by two
and a hundred ninety-eight ninety-nine
nice 7 9 98 96 on 1957 okay that's
actually going to be my probability and
my calculator is telling me now that
should be equal to excuse me 64 on 825
so there's your answer
there's the probability of getting one
prize and one prize only now I promised
excuse me that I'll show you how to
solve this without using you know this
kind of logical method what if you were
three in a student and you could do by
the engl probability well again let's
come back to this piece of information
at the top which is that we are four
tickets there are two prizes and
ninety-eight which have no prize right
so I'm gonna witness out well up the top
my favorable outcomes what I'm really
after is that from these set of two
prizes what I really want is one of
those
okay so out of the out of this team if
you like I want to pick one and then
from this group of 98 I want to pick
three right because I have to have four
tickets in total and I don't care which
ones they are or what order they're in I
just want one of these and three and
eight okay and you know what's the total
number of ways to do that well out of
you are a hundred you're picking any
four right well four tickets okay so
what's the probability in total if I
would express this in binomial terms the
probability would be out of these two I
want to pick one so I would say to
choose one right but I also have to pick
my other three tickets and there are 98
different ones I can choose from so it's
98 choose three okay now these are the
favorable outcomes these are the ones I
want right I have to work out what the
total number of outcomes is and that
gives me a probability right well the
total number of outcomes comes from the
100 out of that 100 I have to choose
four okay no you could plug that into
your calculator and you could get the
answer out but just for the sake of it
and to illustrate how these really are
doing the same thing let's go ahead and
evaluate well what's this some choose
notation about NCR what does it actually
give us in terms of factorials and that
kind of thing
well to choose one right what's that
that's 2 factorial on 1 factorial 1
factorial yeah
what's this 98 choose 3 well that's
going to be 98 factorial divided by 3
factorial 95 vector okay so this one NCR
is the other one what's on the
denominator well same kind of pattern
you're going to get 100 factorial on 4
factorial 96 okay make sure you got your
brackets in there because when you have
fractures of the fractions it can be
confusing okay
now let's evaluate some of this right 1
factorial 1 factorial there just 1 so
this this denominator doesn't matter 2
factorial is just to buy one
so out the front I've got it - okay what
are we going to get here well 98
factorial divided by 90
five factorial this is 98 by 97 by 96 by
95 and so on but because I'm dividing by
95 factorial all of the terms after the
95 they disappear right so all I'm left
with is 98 97 96 and all the other ones
have been divided through about its
non-fire factorial okay and then I've
got this three factorial on the bottom
I'll leave that there for a second no I
have on the bottom in just the same way
that the 95 factorial eliminated a whole
bunch of terms from the 98 this 96
factorial will illuminate a whole bunch
of terms off the 100 factorial namely
it'll leave me with 198 sorry 99 98 97
and then all the rest of all have been
divided through by that that's divided
by 4 factorial okay now this is a
fraction on a fraction so to simplify it
a little bit let's get that 4 out from
there that should really go on to the
numerator right over the 4 factorial
rather so I should have to hmm by 4
factorial by the 98 97 96 divided by 3
factorial and that leaves me of these
numbers down the bottom what was left of
the 100 factorial you can see is 4
factorial and this 3 factorial that's 4
by 3 by 2 by 1 that's 3 by 2 by 1 so
when I divide through all I'm left with
is a 4 right so that's 2 by 4 by 98 97
96
all over these four terms okay now does
that look familiar hope so
the order is slightly different but it's
exactly the same thing we worked out
before you see you've got the 4 in the 2
at the front there right and then your
98 97 96 they follow and your
denominator is exactly the same this is
the same fraction this is still 64 on
825 okay so that's how to go about
solving it if I could use binomial
probability and it's worth mentioning
that if you
can you just go here and then you
calculate a little value with it
evaluate that you can more or less go
straight there unless there's you know
many marks devoted to this question or
maybe you want to evaluate the
factorials if you are into unit and yeah
you're not supposed to know about
binomial probability you still can use
this method if you understand it but if
you're not that confident with it then
go about this way it's still just as
logical and it doesn't take that much
more time to work out